let's say that we wanted to multiply
5x squared
and i'll do this in purple
3x to the fifth
what would this equal pause this video
and see if you can reason through that a
little bit
all right now let's work through this
together and really all we're going to
do is use properties of multiplication
and use properties of exponents to
essentially rewrite this expression so
we can just view this if we're just
multiplying a bunch of things it doesn't
matter what order we multiply them in so
you could just view this as 5 times x
squared times 3 times x to the 5th
or
we could multiply our 5 and 3 first so
you could view this as 5
times 3
times 3 times x squared
times x squared times x to the fifth
times
x to the fifth
and now what is 5 times 3
i think you know that that is 15. now
what is
x squared times x to the fifth now some
of you might recognize that exponent
properties would come into play here if
i'm multiplying two things like this we
have the same base and different
exponents that this is going to be equal
to x to the and we add these two
exponents x to the 2 plus 5 power or x
to the seventh power if what i just did
seems counterintuitive to you i'll just
remind you what is x squared x squared
is x times
x and what is x to the fifth that is x
times x times x times x times x and if
you multiply them all together
what do you get well you got seven x's
and you're multiplying them all together
that is x to the seventh and so there
you have it 5x squared times 3x to the
fifth is 15
x to the seventh power so the key is is
look at these coefficients look at these
numbers the five and the three multiply
those and then
for any variable you have if you have x
here so you have a common base then you
can add those exponents and what we just
did is known as multiplying monomials
which sounds very fancy but this is a
monomial
monomial and in the future we'll do
multiplying things like polynomials
where we have multiple of these things
added together but that's all it is
multiplying monomials let's do one more
example and let's use a different
variable this time just to get some
variety in there
let's say we want to multiply the
monomial 3t to the seventh power
times another monomial
negative 4 t
pause this video and see if you can work
through that
all right so i'm going to do this one a
little bit faster i'm going to look at
the 3 and the negative 4 and i'm going
to multiply those first and i'm going to
get a negative 12.
and then if i were to
want to multiply the t to the seventh
times t once again they're both the
variable t is our base so that's going
to be t to the seventh times t to the
first power that's what t is that's
going to be t
to the seven plus one power or t to the
eighth but there you go
we are done again we've just multiplied
another set of monomials